Just where we got started with this.
When I do want to address the fact that I recently covered respite in on another
one of my channels,
so we kind of thought is it really necessary to do it here on biographics as
well.
However,
it has been requested so much that here we are.
If you want to check out that other video,
I'm going to link to that below as well.
But for now,
let's get into it.
Grigori recipes in was a Russian peasants who claimed to have mystic healing
powers and he even went so far as to see that he was the second coming of
Christ.
The formed his own Culson even manipulated members of the role Romanov family
into believing that the truly was a holy man.
Once he had everyone wrapped around his little finger,
he used his influence over the Russian government.
Since his decisions contributed to the downfall of the remnant of dynasty for
years,
he claims that he struggles between the forces of good and evil.
Many priests believed that his power is,
didn't come from God at all,
is that he was actually the antichrist
regarding recipes in was born on January the 20th 1869 in east Siberia and
village called Krakow screen via Siberia had been something of a dumping ground
for Russia's criminals and there were a lot of prison colonies that were full of
men doing hard labor.
There were all seeing people there who had been exiled to Siberia for their
religious or political beliefs.
It is one of the coldest and most difficult places to live and survival.
There is a constant struggle.
Recipes and his father,
he was a peasant farmer into Korea and his mother gave birth to seven children
before he was born.
All of them died during childbirth or in early infancy,
so it was actually the first to survive the harsh Siberia,
and winter is a boy and he claims that he would have visions of the future and
the angels appeared to him in his dreams.
He knew things about his neighbors that he couldn't possibly know,
which was enough evidence to make the locals believe him.
He could heal horses.
Who were sick just by touching them,
so I'm going to just believed that he was the second coming of Christ and that
he was simply touched by God.
Others believed that he was demonic and it could potentially be working with a
devil in his teens and early twenties it would seem that the latter is true
because he was apparently very badly behaved.
He would drink,
he would steal Lynn's head,
generally just get on everyone's nerves.
At 28 years old,
he was married and had four children with his wife and we met in a neighboring
village.
He had a reputation of being an abusive alcoholic and also cheated on his wife.
One day he stole a horse.
When word got out that he was a horse thief.
Instead of facing the consequences,
he gallops towards a local monastery for sanctuary and ended up staying with the
Christian brothers for several months.
They had convinced him to find God and changes evil ways and name's Margarie
became his mentor and he decided to actually join the order and to become a
monk.
He abandoned his family in favor of traveling from place to place.
Evangelizing to various villages.
Many historians believe that if he spent so much time walking through the forest
of Siberia was always guaranteed that he would run into a cult called the
Christie.
These people were an offshoot of the Russian Orthodox Church.
Many of their members would actually show up to a normal mass on Sunday and have
secret meetings in the woods.
They believed that salvation could only be achieved through purging sin.
They would perform ceremonies where they choked one another and led to go at the
last moment so they would get high on asphyxiation.
They spoke in tongues and would spin and dance until they felt drunk.
They work themselves into a frenzy and then fall to the ground.
Then they would let out of their pencil top desires by having sex with whoever
was lying next to them and a massive Audrey respiration continued to travel and
evangelize the Christian faith.
But this wasn't your normal run of the mill visit from someone with a Bible.
These monk wanderers what not allowed to bathe and recipes in sometimes wash
shackles as he walks to make himself feel pain on purpose.
This was supposed to be an atonement for his sins.
By the time he returned to his village to see his family and friends again,
he was a completely changed man.
His eyes,
his dad on with a frightening intensity,
and he said that his visions from God as they were stronger than ever,
even though he only just got home,
he told his wife that he needed to use the basement as a meeting place for his
religious group where he continued to have orgies with his Christy friends
one day recipes and claims that the Virgin Mary appeared before him and told him
to go to Saint Petersburg to help the royal family.
The idea that the royal family,
you could need help from a peasant man in Siberia was totally insane.
So well,
how on earth did someone like Rasputin's make his way into the royal palace?
What it sends out that he's meant from the monastery.
Mccurry was actually the former religious advisor to the Romanovs.
He was likely able to use Macquarie's connections do attract a noble clients who
believed in Rasputin's abilities and people were simply amazed at his powers.
Rich people.
They were willing to travel all the way to his small village to be healed by
him,
like hollering.
He sends a letter of introduction to one of his friends in some pieces,
but I couldn't.
Rasputin went on the long journey to that city.
He met the ship harm again and say high level priest named Sergei Triffin off
who is better known as Elliot.
All of us,
the men were shocked by Rasputin's disheveled appearance.
He smelled truly awful and just stare.
It was terrifying.
He was able to dilate his eyes at will,
making them appear to be almost fully black,
but once the priest saw his healing ability,
he said that he must be a saint who was gifted by the powers of God,
the recipes,
and truly did norcat at all about what people thought of him.
He would pick his nose and eat it in front of dignified people.
Lynn's mark and aristocratic women for their ass.
He actually became good friends with princess milk.
Erin's Anastasia of Montenegro who were nicknamed of a crew sisters because of
the shape of their noses.
They were not Russian,
but they still managed to marry into the room and our family that actually both
been heavily involved in mysticism and the occult sins.
They both manipulated that way,
ends up marrying members of the royal family.
They were often treated as outcasts by the rest of the aristocracy,
so they bonded with recipes and took him under their wing.
All of this was perfect timing because Sarina Alexandra Room and office just
lost stuff.
First spiritual adviser,
a man named Dr Felipe.
She believed that he helps her in San Nicholas has a son and heir to the throne.
After having only daughters.
He claims on his deathbed that she would meet another hoodie man very soon,
who would take his place almost immediately off to this,
the cro sisters introduced grass boot and do the siren Sarina at a party.
The sisters had been the ones who help the Sarina find to previous mystic.
So when Alexandra learned of the stories of Rasputin's miraculous healing
abilities,
she knew that she wanted him to help us.
On Alexi,
he was born with hemophilia,
which is a condition that prevents the blood from clotting.
This means that even a small scrape can be massive blood loss.
They never told respites and about their son's condition at the party,
and it was a secret.
They had attempted to keep quiet.
Alexandra was still considering whether or not she could trust this peasant from
Siberia,
but one day I'd like to say fell Lil and scraped his knee and the bleeding was
not stopping recipes into showed up out of nowhere to the royal pilot is
demanding to see the boy.
He said that he had a vision from God and this and this.
Without him,
the prince would die.
In reality,
he most likely learned about this insider information from the cro sisters,
but to the gods and the royal family.
They were shocked.
You wondering how we could have possibly known once he was allowed to see him.
He told the doctors to leave so that he could use his healing powers almost
immediately,
and I say actually did begin to heal,
and this was enough to convince Alexandra that he was truly a holy man who had
magical healing powers.
Watson data scientists and historians believe that this was not magic.
Surprise surprise,
but that he was actually preventing the doctors from giving Aleksi Aspirin,
which would thin his blood and only make as hemophilia was within just a few
months recipes and became a regular installment in the Romanov Family Mansion.
He began to give drugs like morphine and cocaine to the SAR,
claiming that they would help him with his various elements.
They would get high together on a regular basis.
This all became addicted,
which I already made him want respite and to come by the palace more often.
The Sarina would get migraine headaches and suffered from anxiety and respite
and was able to take away her pain and get it to relax.
Soon enough,
the sovereign Sarina,
they began to feel a dependency on him and he started to visit at least once a
week.
Rasputin called Alexandra and Nicholas.
Mama and Papa is if he was one of the kids,
he began to pray with the children at night and tell them bedtime stories.
This made the nanny very nervous because the oldest daughters were already
beginning to go through puberty.
One of the maids also claims that Rasputin had raped her.
However,
the Sarina trusted respite and so much that she accused the made of lying and
fire tower the night he tried to kick her ass Putin out of the nursery,
but the children claims that recipes and was their friends and complained that
the nanny was mean so well.
She was fired as well.
It was clear that recipe Newton's clause were deep in the royal family and her
to get away with just about anything.
Newspapers around some Peter's back.
They again,
is a prince.
Stories about the incident saying that recipe using was very literally lessons
and the princesses beds,
recipes,
and lived in an apartment in St Petersburg where his followers could come and
have meetings with them.
Women would all show up with a hot dish and they had potluck style parties.
They gathered around the table with him sitting at the center recipes in,
we'll sit in silence staring into space.
When suddenly he would have began to mumble something.
The women would immediately stop talking and hopes of understanding what he was
trying to say.
He would then grab paper and desperately write down whatever was on his mind
first.
I'm insane.
Unexpectable reason.
This was incredibly attractive to these men.
They believed that he was the second coming of Christ and they would offer to go
with him into his bedroom and have sex with him.
One disciple in particular,
oh,
you're Latina,
had so much faith in him that she left her husband and children in audit and
live in his apartment.
She forced everyone to address him as got witnesses,
opened the back door to see Olga holding his penis and screaming,
you are Christ and I am yours,
and who ever walked in on this unfortunate scene while they slowly backed away,
shutting the door on their way out,
often learning about the scandal,
police officers were ordered to follow him to see what he would do.
They reported that he would hire prostitutes on almost a daily basis and bring
them into bath houses.
Now you would think that if he was paying for a bath on a daily basis,
he might actually smell good.
According to testimony is he would bring a prostitute into a private room where
they would both get undressed.
He would then take his leather belts and begin beating the woman claiming that
he would beat the sin of lechery out of our soul.
Then he would have sex with errands,
leave the bath house without even touching the water.
It was once witness leaving a bath house and screaming at the demons that he
could feel inside of him.
He would say that he could see the devil in himself and he said that there was a
battle over a soul going on.
Now obviously this might sound like he was tripping on one of the many drugs
that he happened to be taking,
but remember these two priests,
Bishop Hamon again and all well,
they happen to hear about Rasputin's screaming about demons in public and this
was damaging the reputation since they were the ones who introduced grass boots
into some Petersburg society.
How are they going and any and all amber Strasberg until you confront him about
what he was doing.
They accused him of using the devil to have these healing powers.
How am I getting grabbed her ass or you can buy the penis and screams that he
was thinking with that rather than his brain.
These do came prepared with a giant wooden crucifix,
which they use the beaten just about as bloody as he would beat those
prostitutes in a bath house,
but the power of Christ did not compel him.
Rasputin tattled on them to the Serena's saying that they were trying to murder
him.
How am again Nancy earlier doorway.
Then both sent into ag and Elliot Eleodoro fled to Finland's dressed as a woman
so that no one could trace where he was going at the same time respite and
decided that he needed a break from the city and visited his home in Siberia.
It turns out that and he adored.
Trudy was trying to kill recipes and then he lays a confessed to all of the
details in a biography.
He was convinced that Rasputin was the antichrist,
so he hired a disfigured prosecutor named Keyona Goosey to kill him.
She had been so abused by a former clients that they had cut her nose off her
face,
just leaving a gaping hole in the door,
told her the stories of how respite in beaten and abused of the sex workers.
She showed up to his village and waited for him outside of his home respite and
received a telegram in the mail and left the house.
He needed to go to the post office to send a reply.
It was then that he noticed a woman standing and staring at him.
He decided that she looks like a perfect [inaudible],
so he walked over to give her some arms and preach the gospel to her.
When she got close enough to him,
she stabbed him in the stomach repeatedly.
She was so insistent on trying to kill him that she even dug our hands into his
stomach and pulls out his intestines.
On that very same day,
Franz Ferdinand was assassinated and it was one of the many events that trigger
the beginning of World War One.
Instead of being by that Soren Sarina sign to give us advisement recipes and
we're stuck in East Siberia in hospital.
He knew him from his injuries.
After hearing the news of the impending Great War recipes and wrote a letter to
the SAR pleading with him to not go to war,
he wrote,
we will all drown in blood.
The disaster is great,
the misery infinite,
but the Saul did not want to listen to Rasputin for the first time in his
career,
people were cheering for him in the streets and they were supporting fighting
for the glory of Russia,
the Sod Beth,
the royal palace so that he could fight with the Russian soldiers.
Alexandra was all alone and after Rasputin heals,
he returned to the royal palace and it's became a right hand advisor.
Runs saw by proxy over the course of two years recipes and personally appointed
several ministers of the interior,
but he was completely uneducated in politics,
so the men be put into power were completely competence.
World War One was devastating.
Millions of Russian men died in this war.
People were struggling to find work and the cost of bread doubles on top of all
of this.
The Serena trusted a madmen,
the entire country that had enough.
The Russian people,
they basically had no choice but to have a revolution.
Even though he's the volume of the assassination attempt to reduce Boudin's
health began to decline and soon enough that you could no longer heal people.
He wrote in his journal that he knew that he would die soon and see,
you already had made peace with us.
He believed that God was about to make a sacrifice in order to save the Russian
people similar to how Jesus Christ had died on the cross.
He wrote to Sarina,
Alexandra,
if one of your relations brings upon my death,
and none of your family will remain alive for more than two years,
they will all be killed by the Russian people.
Tell your relatives that I've already paid for them and my blood,
I shall be killed.
I am no longer among the living,
pray and be strong.
During an easing in parliament,
one of the politicians actually called respite and a dark force and said that he
was sick and tired of this dirty peasant controlling the country and that he
would personally kill him himself if the man was not taken out of power.
Sarinor.
Alexandra's nephew was a man named Felix you support event.
He was one of the many people who wanted him dead.
He heard a lot about recipes and his reputation with the ladies use above was
married to a woman named arena and she was considered to be one of the most
beautiful women in the city of Saint Petersburg.
It was recommended that you support was bisexual then so that the couple were
swingers with an adventurous sex life invited respite and to join them claiming
this I Rina had taken their open relationship too far into that.
He believed that she was stricken with a sex addiction.
He sends that she needed Rasputin's helps you heal the demons inside.
Defat after gaining Rasputin's trust you support for met up with two of his co
conspirators.
They were planning to assassinate him.
The men picks up respite in in a car and drove them to the use of off mansion
where they led him into a basement dining room.
The table was set up to appear as though they're just had a large party.
They told him that I already know is with our guests upstairs and look.
She would come downstairs later to have a healing ceremony.
They encouraged him to eat and drink while they waited for her.
Without in mind,
they started to hand him tiny cakes and glasses of wine recipes and had new idea
that all of the food and drink was laced with cyanide.
Two and a half hours later,
you support could not believe this recipe to not drop dead.
Yet he began to believe the rumors that he truly did have demonic powers and
that poisoned would not be enough to kill him.
He rushed upstairs and grabbed his revolver and returned to the basement
pointing the gun.
At Rasputin.
The monk simply stood there staring straight ahead.
He did not beg for his life for show any sign of fear.
He short respite and crumpled down to the floor and then shared and then went
upstairs to party.
After some time into the celebration,
you support began to feel a sense of dread.
He walked down to the basement with the doctor,
runs,
leans in to check for a heartbeat recipe mutton's eyes opened and he lunged at
use above.
The doctor fainted on the spot,
use of pushed the demon off.
Emmons scrambled upstairs to tell his friends that were him to come back to
life.
They ran down to the basement and he was gone.
He had called up the basement stairs and with slinking his way across the
courtyard use above,
shot him point blank in the head and five other men pulled their revolvers out
to riddle his body with bullets.
They stopped Rasputin's body in the trunk of the car and driven to a river where
they shoved him in a hole in the ice.
When his body was later found,
his hands weren't up as if he was pressing against the ice.
In an attempt to escape,
there was even water in his lungs suggesting that he was still breathing.
Even after all of that,
after hearing the story,
people were convinced that he had truly come back to life again as a Zombie.
So indeed,
they dug up his body and burns the remains,
but not too before cutting.
Oftens preserving his legendary penis.
Indeed,
it is now on display in a museum and some pages back
soon after his death.
Respite and his prophecy really did come through the entire Romanov family was
executed during the Bolshevik revolution in Russia would never be the same
again.
So I already have you found the video.
Interesting.
If you did,
these do gives a thumbs up below.
Do not forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several days a week.
So hit that subscribe button,
hit the notification belt,
and you'll learn all about that and as always,
see you next time.